in the last video we talked about how
the serbians were able to hold back the
austro-hungarians at the beginning of
world war one but eventually they they
had to give in they they were they were
essentially uh
they couldn't hold up against the
combined forces of the bulgarians the
austro-hungarians and the germans and
they were able to roll through in 1915
and then we wait until 1918 for the
allies to essentially recapture serbia
now what is
noteworthy there's many noteworthy
things in world war one and obviously we
can't cover all of them is just what a
huge loss world war one was to the
serbian people just as a little bit just
as a little bit of context very small
country we're talking 4.5 million people
as we enter into world war one with a
reasonably i guess this is relative to
the size of com of the country it was a
decent sized army but with an army on
the order of we're talking on the order
of 400 000 on the order of 400 000
soldiers and this was pretty much
everyone in in the country who could be
in the army was essentially in the army
over the course of the serbian campaign
and the macedonian front you essentially
have the serbian army getting decimated
you have sixty percent of the serbian
army dies
sixty percent roughly sixty percent of
the serbian army is killed and even from
a population point of view the serbian
population is reduced by 16
16 of the serbian population civilian
and military is dead
is dead by the end of world war one so a
lot of countries
suffered horribly during world war one
there's many notable ones france the
russian empire we could go on and on and
on
but it would be hard to argue that any
country suffered more
suffered more than than than what the
serbians did 60 of their military dead
16 percent of their population